is a hot dog a sandwich yes okay but  what is a sandwich some stuff between  two pieces of bread lettuce meat cheese  vegetables of some kind really doesn't  matter for it to be a sandwich as long  as it's between bread which a hot dog  definitely is and my grandma told me so  so that's that if we're talking about  the two-handed sandwich theory which  good hot dogs require two hands if  you're eating your hot dog with one hand  grow up put some stuff on the hot dog  and we're just gonna top our hot dog  with a spicy ketchup a dejenes and  pickled fresno chilis  it's clearly a sandwich i was doing what  sandwiches do you know  but wouldn't that just make it a taco  i'm done